[Music]  g'day i'm bernie shakeshaft  australia's local hero for 2020  being an aussie fills me with pride but  what does it actually mean  to be an aussie and to play an active  part in our communities  my friends and i think we've worked it  out  aussies are role models  [Music]  in sport the arts  [Applause]  in classrooms and life  aussies recognised the need to be allies  [Music]  and a champion for equality  aussies reach out a helping hand to  those in need  aussies know that our land sustains us  [Music]  aussies are champions for gender  equality  [Music]  aussies know that our multicultural  diversity makes communities stronger  you don't need to be famous or to win an  award  [Music]  being an aussie is about what each of us  does in our own communities  and how we lift each other up so get to  it  keep being an aussie and making  australia  an even better place to call home  you